bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat poursuivre dans un
instant l'audition des manuels macron le
ministre de l'économie qui a été
interrogé la semaine dernière par les
sénateurs de la commission des affaires
étrangères commission présidée par
l'ancien premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin
la semaine dernière le ministre de
l'économie s'est exprimé autour de la
question des investissements étrangers
en france et il ya du mieux sur ce sujet
puisque la france en 2014 a accueilli 10
% des investissements créateurs
d'emplois de plus par rapport à l'année
précédente cela s'explique parce que la
france est plus attractive en matière
d'innovation en matière de compétitivité
mais reste des défauts à corriger
notamment la fiscalité que beaucoup
d'entreprises continuent à juger trop
élevé pour s'installer en france tout de
suite donc retour à l'audition des
manuels macron c'était la semaine
dernière au sénat
le sujet d'où selon lui c'est celui de
l'attractivité de l'économie française
et de notre capacité donc à nous ouvrir
vous avez évoqué les investissements
directs étrangers il ya les
investissements financiers
en tout cas tout ce qui permet d'une
part de faire venir et bien de
l'investissement étranger pour
fertiliser notre capital nos entreprises
ou développer d'autres installations
industrielles
participe de la stratégie française on
pourra y revenir dans la discussion mais
quand on parle de compétitivité et de
productivité notre économie et
d'attractivité c'est bien que nous avons
besoin pour développer
justement un appareil d'offres
industrielle est bien de l'innovation de
nos forces de travail mais également
d'un capital français et étrangers et là
il faut bien prendre aussi en
considération ce que sont les réalités
de l'écosystème français où nous avons
aujourd'hui une organisation
capitalistique qui n'est pas optimal
là aussi on pourra y revenir si vous le
souhaitez qui ne permet pas de financer
manière la plus satisfaisante qu'ils
soient notre économie nous nous avons
besoin des investissements des
investisseurs internationaux
nous en avons besoin en tant
qu'investisseur au sein de nos grandes
entreprises pour les aider à se
développer
un niveau d'ailleurs qui est stable il
faut bien le dire de qu'une dizaine
d'années mais qui est conséquent nous en
avons besoin pour se développer aussi
sur le territoire national parce
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de l' épargne
financière des ménages français est bien
et surinvesti devrais-je dire dans
l'immobilier et dans le financement
obligataire beaucoup plus qu'elle menait
dans le financement en fonds propres de
notre économie nous allons proposer des
mesures pour modifier cela il faut
ajuster quelques régulation financière
pour également un palier mais dans ce
contexte là la park joue véritablement
les financeurs internationaux les
acteurs industriels ou financiers
internationaux elle est extrêmement
stratégique parce que c'est celle qui
permet de développer notre économie
d'apporter du capital là où il y en a
besoin et donc également de créer de
l'emploi et pour ce faire on vit dans un
paradoxe qui est tangible c'est que nous
sommes un pays attractif
les chiffres sont bons je vais y revenir
dans quelques instants
et la dynamique est positive
quand on regarde aujourd'hui la totalité
des ide ou les investissements directs
de certains pays stratégiques comme la
chine par exemple en france ne serait ce
que sur le site parisien
on a une dynamique qui plus forte que
quand on se compare à nos voisins et en
même temps l'image reste perfectible
si j'osais de formuler ainsi puisque 68
% des responsables d'entreprises
étrangères implantées en france jusque
là france n'est pas très ou pas du tout
attractive
donc il faut bien on vit avec ses
éléments qui sont des éléments de
perception qui ne sont pas toujours très
bon mais je crois que le plus difficile
c'est de faire voeu de faire venir si je
puis dire les investisseurs une première
fois que quand je regarde les chiffres
là aussi dans deux tiers des cas celles
et ceux qui ont investi en france
réinvestisse donc il ya beaucoup si je
puis dire de distorsions cognitives
quand on regarde nos partenaires
internationaux qu'il faut savoir traiter
c'est aussi le rôle de la diplomatie
économique
alors peut-être un point sur la réalité
des choses telle quelle est la situation
la france comme je le disais est un site
attractif pour les investissements
internationaux d'abord parce que elle a
des atouts qui vous sont famille mais
j'y reviendrai pas c'est un des points
d'entrée sur un marché domestique et le
marché
domestique européen qui est un marché de
500 millions de consommateurs c'est un
bon point d'entrée parce que nous avons
un pays qui est au standard de
réglementation sur beaucoup de sujets on
pourra y revenir dans la discussion au
niveau européen est un pays où la
dynamique de consommation est forte de
dire quand on regarde le marché français
soit en termes de grande distribution
soit en termes de marchés industriels
soit en termes d'innovation soit en
termes d'accès des consommateurs aux
marchés les plus innovants nous sommes
l'un des marchés les plus complets de
l'union européenne donc on est un bon
point d'entrée pour les investisseurs
étrangers
ensuite des infrastructures sont de
grande qualité est là sont au meilleur
niveau européen quand on se compare aux
allemands sur ce sujet nous sommes
meilleurs publics ne pas réinvestir
depuis plusieurs années et c'est je
pense d'ailleurs un choix qui n'est pas
optimale de leurs points de vue comme
l'a bien dit le rapport fraîcheur de
l'année dernière la main d'oeuvre est
une main d'oeuvre à haut niveau de
formation avec m un modèle performant et
une tarification de l'énergie ce qui est
stratégique
aussi pour beaucoup d'investisseurs qui
est également compétitive
on avait un déficit de comptes de
compétitivité sur les électro et gazons
intensifs on est en train de combler par
les mesures prises et les discussions en
cours avec edf et et cnr mais en moyenne
sinon nous sommes compétitifs sur ce
point et puis on a des instruments qui
restent attractifs je dois bien le dire
qui sont importants pour nos grandes
entreprises mais qu'ils sont aussi pour
les investisseurs étrangers
je pense en particulier au crédit impôt
recherche qui est un instrument
plébiscité par ses acteurs est
clairement reconnu enfin on a
véritablement les caractéristiques de
notre population avec une population
jeune et bien formés quand on se compare
là aussi au niveau européen
c'est une réalité avec une vraie
dynamique entrepreneuriale ce qui est un
changement des dernières années mais où
quand on le regarde les aspirations des
jeunes c'est véritablement de t'être de
devenir entrepreneur et une dynamique
forte puisque nous sommes le premier
pays d'europe continentale en termes de
création de start-up 1500 créé par an et
paris est aujourd'hui la seconde ville
européenne après londres en termes de
start up dans le domaine du numérique
ensuite quand on regarde les chiffres
fort de ces atouts notre pays accueille
sur son sol le septième stock
d'investissements directs dans le monde
et le troisième en europe
nous sommes le premier pays en europe en
termes d'implantations industrielles et
plus de vingt mille sociétés étrangères
sont aujourd'hui présentes sur le
territoire ce qui fait travailler
environ deux millions de salariés
français
je ne parle là que des salariés qui
travaillent pour le compte d'entreprises
étrangères il ne faut pas méconnaître
quand on fait ses calculs tous les
salariés d'entreprises travaillons
essentiellement à l'international qu'il
s'agisse de luxe de l'aéronautique ou de
l'automobile ou de l'agroalimentaire en
termes de flux annuels d'investissements
étrangers la france se situe au 10e rang
mondial en 2015 avec des entrées qui
depuis 2013 sont supérieures à celles
enregistrées par l'allemagne
est ce que ces classements sont
satisfaisants tous égards pas totalement
on a été mieux classé que 7e en ide et
les 10e rang mondial alors ya la
concurrence de pays émergents qui ont
pris une place importante avant les
difficultés qui sont en train de de
connaître mais il faut bien le dire la
mauvaise perception qui existent encore
est un élément aujourd'hui de rigidité
qui à mon avis se traite justement par
notre action diplomatique et les
initiatives con qu'on peut prendre alors
si on regarde notre évolution
justement dans le temps sur longue
période le montant annuel
d'investissement direct étranger en
france est globalement stable on est
autour de 20 milliards d'euros en
moyenne sur les 15 dernières années sans
tendance à la baisse mais enfin quand on
connaît la déformation de l'économie
mondiale ça veut dire que nous ne
partons pas en quelque sorte
une dynamique qui correspond à notre
part de marché et fait qu'on se
maintienne en volume n'est pas à mes
yeux pleinement satisfaisant parce que
ça veut dire que nous fragilisons en
termes de parts de marché paris est la
deuxième destination en europe des
investissements étrangers néanmoins et
elle a augmenté de 22 % l'année dernière
ce qu'il a un bon signal
il y avait eu un gros décalage fait avec
londres / an sur les dernières années la
dynamique a été plus forte à paris qu'à
londres essentiellement d'ailleurs porté
par les chinois entre autres ce qui
montre la saturation du marché londonien
d'une part et le fait que nous étions
nous n'étions pas au niveau dynamique
qui l'été les gitans en termes de
projets d'investissement là aussi les
chiffres montrent une amélioration selon
l'étude dan sun yang le nombre de
projets d'investissements étrangers
augmenter de 30% depuis 2012 et selon
les chiffres qui ont été publiés mardi
22 mars par business france le nombre
d'emplois créés ou maintenus en 2015 du
fait des décisions d'investissements
étrangers a augmenté de 27% par rapport
à 2014
c'est à dire un total en 2015 de 33700
et on a eu donc en 2015
des milliers de décisions d'un millier
de décisions d'investissement en
direction de la france avec des cas
concret extrêmement important que je
veux ici rappeler facebook intel samsung
nokia cisco à deux reprises qui a
d'abord qui s'est engagé à 100 millions
piqué a doublé son ticket
d'investissement coca cola microsoft et
c'est ce qui est important de voir dans
les cas donc les plus emblématiques que
j'ai cités tu peux y revenir en deux
secondes
c'est qu'il s'agisse de samsung intel de
facebook de cisco microsoft sont des cas
où sont des entreprises qui ont décidé
d'investir d'investir dans l'écosystème
d'innovation c'est à dire que ce sont
des investissements de type financiers
dans des parts minoritaires ou
majoritaires ou en totalité de start up
française certains d'ailleurs
investissions dans les mains start-up si
je prends le cas d' intel ou samsung
ils ont décidé d'investir des tic est
considérable dans une entreprise qui
s'appelle sigfox qui est basée près de
toulouse et qui développe un réseau bas
débit pour les objets connectés qui est
une véritablement un
ce qu'on appelle une des licornes
française ils ont aussi décidé d'ouvrir
des fonds à destination de tout
l'écosystème d'innovation et ils ont
installé des activités de recherche soit
dans le traitement des données nomma
soit dans l'intelligence artificielle
qui sont des segments sur lesquels nous
sommes considérés comme réputé comme
étant extrêmement compétitif parce que
nous avons des chercheurs de talent
parce que nous avons un environnement
fiscal favorable grâce au crédit impôt
recherche
et d'ailleurs quand on regarde les
choses nous avons des chercheurs de
talents peu cher puisque il ya une
proportion aujourd'hui non négligeable
de chercheurs français installé sur la
silicon valley pour que vous ayez un
ordre d'idée le chercheur français qui
fait la même chose à saclay paris
toulouse lyon bordeaux et sur la silicon
valley il est payé trois fois moins cher
en france il est bien payé mais qu'est
ce qui se passe simplement c'est qu'il
ya une inflation salariale très forte
sur la silicon valley chose dont on
parle trop peu souvent mais
l'augmentation des prix de l'immobilier
la grande difficulté donc pour se loger
et pour circuler et le fait que la
silicon valley repose sur un système qui
en fait a beaucoup rééquilibrer le
facteur travail par rapport au facteur
capital sont des éléments qu'il faut
prendre en compte vous n'avez pas de
clause de non concurrence dans le droit
californien donc un salarié qui est très
bon l'entreprise doit le payer beaucoup
parce que sinon du jour au lendemain il
peut aller chez deux concurrents et ça a
créé une dynamique salariale extrêmement
forte dont nous pouvons capter si je
puis dire l'un des rééquilibrages et les
cas que je viens de citer son dd je
pense des bonnes illustrations je citais
également nokia qui donc comme vous le
savez a repris l'entreprise alcatel
ça n'est pas évidemment le choix qu'on
aurait
privilégiée mais il faut bien constater
que alcatel n'était plus en situation de
porter ces projets de gagner la bataille
de la semaine j'ai on a pu ainsi
construire un champion européen mais
dans le cadre de la discussion et en
particulier de l'autorisation relatifs
aux investissements étrangers
nous avons une discussion extrêmement
détaillée avec nokia et il apparaissait
que le site france était un site
compétitifs en termes de recherche que
le crédit impôt recherche a joué un rôle
décisif et que donc non seulement nokia
a décidé de préserver les structures de
r et d et alcatel à villarceaux et
lannion mais a réinvesti sur ces
dernières est réinvesti dans
l'écosystème d'innovation ce qui vous
montre quand même la nature de la
dynamique et l afo ses caractéristiques
et ses secteurs enfin donc pour finir
sur les constats les classements donc
montre permettre d'illustrer cette
situation française la place de la
france a nettement progressé dans
plusieurs classements internationaux
d'attractivité et de compétitivité n'a
gagné sur les trois dernières années
dans le classement
n'diaye convaincante fait dans le sind
ex du cabinet est écornée on se place
qui est une enquête sur l'attractivité
perçue par les investisseurs
internationaux nous sommes maintenant au
huitième rang on a gagné onze places ces
deux dernières années dans le rapport
doing business de la banque mondiale
nous sommes malgré tout qu 27e rang mais
nous étions 38e en 2012 parce qu'on a
travaillé aussi les critères sans fausse
naïveté et l'amélioration réelle
et puis il ya des améliorations des
critères qui sont prises en compte par
ces agences et nous avons gagné une
place en 2015 dans le classement de
compétitivité du forum de davos en nous
plaçant au 22e rang alors cette
contribution des investissements
étrangers à notre économie comme je le
disais elle est positive pour ce qui est
des start-up je n'y reviens pas pour ce
qui est de l'investissement productif
français comme je l'évoquais et contenu
même de nos caractéristiques et il faut
là dessus m tout de suite les choses au
clair sur un autre débat qui revêt
parfois quelques allures passionnel en
france c'est que nous aimons
l'investissement étranger nous aimons
être attractif mais bien souvent nous
n'aimons pas les investisseurs étrangers
ce qui est quand même un problème quand
on veut faire les choses
en vrai c'est à dire que
parce que il certains ne savent pas se
faire aimer mais nous ne sommes pas sans
une forme d'esprit de paradoxes nous
avons eu à vivre sur beaucoup de
situations et je pense que du cousseau à
la fois qui est un effort de pédagogie
mutuelle qui soit fait mais il faut
aussi bien dire que quand on parle la
plupart du temps de ses investissements
directs étrangers
on ne parle pas de prise de contrôle
c'est je pense la nature de cet
investissement qu'il faut clarifier il y
en a parfois faut voir dans quel cadre
je pourrai répondre à ce sujet toutes
les questions que vous aurez mais bien
souvent ce ne sont pas des prises de
contrôle mais des participations je
l'évoqué en introduction les entreprises
du cac 40 ont besoin de capitaux pour se
développer
nous n'avons pas la base actionnariale
sont des choix historiques français pour
faire aider nos entreprises à se
développer à l'international et donc
nous avons besoin de capitaux étrangers
néanmoins ces capitaux sont à un niveau
conséquent mais stable ils sont
représente aujourd'hui 40 5,3 pour cent
du capital des entreprises du cac 40
il ya dix ans c'était 46,7 % on voit
bien qu'on est un étiage stabilise mais
qui est nécessité est bon je pense qu'il
faut d'ailleurs cherché au maximum à
attirer ils viennent beaucoup d'ailleurs
deux pays émergents du golf de mike
latine de la chine des capitaux long
terme qui peuvent être très utiles pour
nos entreprises là où parfois notre
ouverture s'est fait vers des financeurs
qui étaient parfois court termiste et
dans les exigences en rentabilité court
terme ou les arbitrages n'étaient pas
forcément les plus aligné avec
l'intérêt même des territoires ou des
entreprises sur le long terme
néanmoins nous avons besoin de cette
ouverture dans le même temps 96 % des
investissements directs étrangers en
france sont détenus par les économies
avancées les etats unis restent le
premier investisseur étranger en france
et donc il faut sortir aussi d'une
mythologie qu'on peut avoir qui est
celle du raid d'une économie émergente
dans le pays ce n'est pas conformité
avec la réalité
l'investissement chinois reste
d'ailleurs relativement faible dans
notre pays la france est désormais le
deuxième pays d'accueil en europe
nous sommes passés devant l'allemagne
mais les investissements chinois demeure
relativement faible et d'ailleurs on
n'investit plus en chine que la chine
investit en france malgré les derniers
investissements constatée là aussi on
pourra y revenir et les investissements
des pays du golfe rappel du golfe pardon
reste également malgré leur visibilité
minimes en volume sont simplement sur
investi sur quelques catégories d'actif
particulier le début du siècle a vu une
très grosse mobilisation de certains
actifs du golfe sur le l'immobilier
européen et en particulier français ce
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas là on a le plus
besoin d'investisseurs étrangers
mais en montant ses investissements
restent relativement modestes
donc je pense qu'il ne faut pas là
dessus que nous ayons si je puis dire
d'états d'âme sur notre capacité à
attirer des investisseurs mais faut le
faire dans un cadre et qui est consiste
à éviter
on est des investisseurs qui viennent à
la rescousse des petits fous d'acteurs
mal en point parce que ça nous met dans
une situation de faiblesse ou là ils
peuvent prendre une part majoritaire et
c'est de fait que nous avons vécu avec
la sphère general electric alstom mais
plutôt qu'ils rendent dans des
situations scène dans des histoires de
croissance ou une participe de ce
développement est donc pour ce faire il
faut agir sans hésiter mais sans pour
autant de naïveté dans certains secteurs
sensibles
l'investissement étranger peut présenter
des risques
c'est le cas de certaines technologies
sensibles et c'est pour ça que il ya un
cadre qui existe qui a d'ailleurs été
développé dans une période que vous
évoquiez monsieur le président instant
votre propos c'est le décret relatif aux
investissements
étrangers en france dont le champ a été
élargie au début de l'année 2014 par
décret justement dans le cadre de
l'opération general electric alstom et
qui vise sur les secteurs stratégiques à
conditionner ces investissements
lorsqu'ils sont sur des technologies ou
des secteurs sensibles et bien à une
autorisation préalable de l'état il ya
des conditions qui doivent être
respectées par les investisseurs mais la
meilleure façon cela étant d'avoir un
actionnariat équilibré reste la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et
notre capacité à développer un capital
propre
là dessus je crois que c'est le meilleur
moyen dans un monde ouvert on veut
réussir c'est d'être offensif alors par
rapport à cette situation
qu'est ce qui est fait et comment nous
comptons justement et bien amélioré les
choses d'abord dé la meilleure façon
d'être attractif d'attirer les bons
investissements
c'est d'être compétitif et ce qui est
bon pour notre économie est bon pour
attirer l'investissement étranger et le
faire dans de bonnes conditions et donc
ce qui permet de rétablir les marges de
nos entreprises permet de stabiliser
l'actionnariat est d'avoir des
stratégies d'investissement offensive
c'est le cic le pacte de responsabilité
et la stratégie de nouvelle france
industrielle ce qui permet en
particulier et bien d'accès des
investissements sur la recherche
développement l'innovation c'est à dire
la différenciation et la montée en gamme
de tons de notre industrie est
particulièrement important dans cette
stratégie
c'est le rôle du crédit impôt recherche
et du crédit impôt innovation qui garde
un caractère fondamental aussi bien pour
les acteurs français que pour les
acteurs étrangers et les choix
d'investissements étrangers et on voit
que le crédit impôt recherche nous aide
dans l'attractivité des investissements
directs à haute valeur ajoutée et c'est
toute la politique de simplification et
la politique en matière de marché du
travail qui elle aussi permet
d'améliorer notre compétitivité et notre
attractivité
car beaucoup des débats que nous avons
sur justement le projet de loi travail
ils sont des débats importants en termes
d'attractivité
j'ai reçu la semaine dernière avant le
le conseil stratégique de l'attractivité
à dîner à merci les dirigeants
d'entreprise leur question c'est
qu'est-ce que vous faites vraiment
et il la france est un pays qui leur
paraît solide un point d'accès au niveau
européen mais leurs questions c'est un
peu la même que celle qu'ont des
entrepreneurs français sait quelle est
la capacité qu'on me donne en cas de
retournement de cycle ou d'erreurs
économiques à réagir et leur perception
telle que mesurée
aujourd'hui par les indices c'est que
nous sommes un pays très attractif avec
beaucoup d'infrastructures une vraie
qualité de main d'oeuvre mais qui est
plus rigide en encadré adaptation que
d'autres pays c'est en réalité ce n'est
pas totalement faux quand on regarde les
chiffres ça n'est pas faux et donc je
pense que les accords d'entreprise
permettent d'aller en ce sens et de
résoudre une partie des problèmes
ce qu'on a pu faire avec les décisions
de chômage partiel accompagné permettent
de le faire
on a des bons qu'à comme stx qui ont
permis de le montrer et qui permettent
de reprendre sans mauvais jeu de mots la
mer lorsque on a un carnet de commandes
qui redécolle ce qui évite de détruire
du capital productif et du capital
humain et je pense que ce qu'on fait
particulier en matière de licenciement
économique ne se comprend que dans ce
cadre je fais une parenthèse sur ce
sujet étaient d'importance le patron de
cisco qui a été l'un de nos meilleurs
ambassadeurs durant l'année passée était
dire partout que la france était la
prochaine grande chose qui arrivait à
l'économie mondiale il a lui-même décidé
d'investir massivement de réinvestir il
m'a posé trop explicitement la question
il m'a dit dans tous les pays de l'union
européenne ce qui est vrai si j'ai un
problème de productivité et
d'attractivité du site productif je peux
me re organisé en france
je ne peux pas le faire et il est exact
que si vous voulez vous réorganiser en
procédant à des licenciements
économiques qui ne consiste pas à fermer
l'entreprise
mehal a réorganisé à cause de critères
de compétitivité
la france est le seul pays de l'union
européenne qui n'apprécient pas cette
compétitivité au regard de critères liés
aussi productif français mais elle est
appréciée au regard de critères mondiaux
et bien quand on n'est pas compétitif en
france on ne peut pas du coup se
réorganiser bilan des courses on
investit moins parce que c'est dissuasif
et donc si on est bon on doit pouvoir
faire face à ses problèmes de
compétitivité pour notre propre site ce
qui veut dire très concrètement qu'il
s'agisse d'un grand groupe du notte ou
d'une pme si vous êtes basé sur trois
pays et qu'on apprécie votre
compétitivité c'est à dire l'évolution
votre chiffre d'affaires ou de vos
pertes d'exploitation au regard du site
romain polonais et français
on sait très bien ce qui se passe
malheureusement le cas la productivité
et les chiffres des deux premiers vont
compenser une troisième donc a pas de
possibilité de réorganiser le site
france qui peut être la source de vos
pertes c'est pas forcément le cas si on
peut l'apprécier au niveau du site
france et bien à ce moment là on évite
d'ailleurs le choix délibéré de certains
acteurs industriels qui est d'aller
mettre en redressement judiciaire voire
en liquidation les sites considérés
comme non compétitive dont ils veulent
se séparer parce qu'on a créé la
rigidité à l'adaptation
donc on est dans un modèle qui est trop
binaire donc pour ça pour vous faire
toucher du doigt la sensibilité on
pourrait revenir dans la discussion des
débats que nous avons à l'égard de ces
investisseurs internationaux est en
quelque sorte la continuité de nos
débats lorsqu'il s'agit de la
compétitivité de l'agilité de notre
économie et de son attractivité à
l'international et puis au delà des
sujets qui sont ceux qui font la
vitalité notre économie nous avons mené
des actions spécifiques en faveur des
investisseurs en simplifiant le paysage
institutionnel c'est à dire en
fusionnant la fille et du bi et
ubifrance les uns s'occupant
historiquement des investisseurs
internationaux qui se tourner vers notre
économie les autres des pme qui voulait
aller à l'export pour créer cet acteur
unique et business france qui est
l'interface entre nos pme nos acteurs
industriels qui veulent aller à l'export
et les investisseurs internationaux qui
veulent venir investir en france c'est
un outil qui est en train de démontrer
je crois à sa force c'est plus simple
plus accessible plus transparent n'a
pris aussi des mesures qui d'ailleurs
étaient les conséquences des discussions
que nous avions eu en conseil
stratégique de l'attractivité des début
de l'année 2012 des mesures de
simplification en particulier en matière
de tva pour les transporteurs et
logisticiens et de pratiques de
dédouanement qui ont été salués pas
encore je pense améliorer les choses
mais elles ont permis d'améliorer
grandement la situation en matière de
capacité à attirer les talents avec la
réforme qui a été votée dans le cas de
la loi croissance sur les actions
gratuites
la simplification du régime des
impatriés pour attirer les cadres
supérieurs et les dirigeants d'envergure
internationale ou là
dépénalisation enfin plutôt la
suppression de la peine de prison
associé au délit d'entravé qui était
aussi un élément canton se comparer à
l'international qui était dissuasive
pour plusieurs investisseurs au total 35
des 39 actions annoncées dans le cadre
du csa ont été réalisés et les autres
sont en cours de l'être
enfin vous avez demandé une fugue
président la vision des choses sur le
larchitecture ministériel qui a été acté
il ya de cela deux ans bientôt qui a
consisté donc à rattacher le commerce
extérieur tourisme au ministère des
affaires étrangères moi je suis toujours
très prudent sur ce et géographie
institutionnel la france fait partie des
pays qui ont fait le choix de varier
d'une mandature à l'autre ses paysages
parfois même de les varier au sein même
d'une sa demande être d'une même
mandature et je crois moi j'ai c'est
d'être pragmatique en l'espèce ça doit
marcher ça doit marcher donc il faut
faire en sorte que ça marche c'est à
dire que ces redécoupages qui sont
parfois le fruit de vicissitudes
organisationnel ou personnels ne doivent
pas impacter les vrais gens je pense que
dans les deux cas le commerce extérieur
et la politique d'attractivité doit être
efficace et faire partie d'un continuum
quel est l'avantagé que ce soit associée
au quai d'orsay
ça donne plus de cohérence à l'outil
diplomatique et ça permettait d' acte et
cette diplomatie économique portée par
le ministre
cette volonté que l'outil diplomatique
soit mis au service de finalité
économique ça me semble être une bonne
chose qu'elle il avantage quand s'est
rattachée à bercy la continuité d'un
discours économique est son action entre
ce qui est fait à l'intérieur
et ce qui est porté à l'extérieur d'un
contenu même de ce que je viens de dire
c'est que le monde est aujourd'hui
transparent et c'est de toute façon un
continuum qu'elle est l'écueil dans
lequel nous ne devons pas tomber quand
je regardais que c'est de comparer notre
modèle aux autres
notre modèle est acéré en fait n'est pas
le plus usuel celui qui a consisté à
rattacher le commerce extérieur au quai
d'orsay c'est qu'il faut réussir à
maintenir des relations économiques et
commerciales y compris avec des pays ou
des régions avec lesquels nous ne sommes
pas dans les relations diplomatiques
parfois chaude etc ce réalisme
économique dans lequel nous avons
d'ailleurs toujours construire notre
propre développement et dans lequel nos
parts
toner font cela et donc je pense que le
seul risque ce serait que nous
considérions que le commerce extérieur
est un instrument à finalité
diplomatique ce qui n'est pas le cas
c'est la précision que je me permets de
faire ce stade de la discussion
je pense que nous avons des finalités
diplomatique la france a une stratégie
une voix qui est la sienne qui est
indépendante
comment le sait je crois que nous y
sommes toutes et tous attachés mais à
côté de ça il ya toujours eu un réalisme
de notre politique économique de nos z à
l'export de l'accompagnement nos acteurs
internationaux des partenariats qui se
nouent et qui parfois pouvait aller au
delà si je puis dire d'eux des relations
diplomatiques qui avait pu exister et je
pense que c'est important aussi de
préserver les équilibres
c'est ce que font d'ailleurs tous les
pays avec tous les grands pays avec une
grande lucidité et diplomatiques
économiques
donc c'est ça qu'il faut aussi savoir
préserver voilà je peux pas être plus
longues sur le président proposait tous
les sujets qui vous semblera utile de
creuser dans le cadre de la discussion
mais voilà ce que je voulais apporter en
tout cas à la connaissance des uns et
des autres à ce stade et beaucoup
monsieur le ministre un très intéressant
de voir cette réflexion dont on sent
bien la complexité et l'un d'eux est d'y
mettre un peu de l'expérience aux uns
aux autres est un peu de temps pour bien
apprécier parce que c'est sûr que on
peut ajouter aussi l'importance des
études du trésor sur un terrain de
sujets donc on voit bien et on voit bien
aussi tout l'intérêt d'avoir le poids
politique du care parce que par
définition c'est un sujet complexe
un jugement rapide sans doute pas
suffisant j'ai bien roger demande la
parole et il va la voir
merci ce que j'aurai puisqu'il faudra
une chauffarde peut-être avant la fin de
l'édition pour les uns sur le plateau de
public sénat
monsieur le ministre sur la notion que
vous avez évoqué d'où la comparaison ça
allait donner des tas de d'instituts
sûrement plus sympathiques les uns que
les autres mais vous avez évoqué l'idée
que parfois pour un investisseur
comparer la france la pologne
on pourra toujours comparer avec la
somalie
on sera toujours bien plus cher ici
qu'en somalie et et la pologne je la
connais un peu pour des affaires
familiales
franchement quand je vais à varsovie et
quand je discute avec les gens de ma
famille ils rêvent plutôt de france que
de ceux de pologne propres et donc la
question que je me pose c'est comment
est-ce qu'on peut rendre la fierté à
nous mêmes et comment est-ce qu'on peut
être capable de se de nous juger nous
mêmes sur nos compétences et nos
qualités
j'ai l'impression parfois on ne sait pas
le faire-- et le prendre en compte deux
petites questions
vous avez évoqué le fait que les
capitaux on n'a pas l'habitude de les
mettre sur les entreprises mais plutôt
sur la pierre est ce qu'on pourrait être
capable de à partir du volume annuel de
ce qui est placé à la caisse d'épargné
du volume pratiquement annuel de ce que
nous savons consommer pour construire du
logement social et de l'accession
est-ce qu'on peut pas imaginer de créer
un autre produit plus attractif mais qui
dans son attractivité aurait aussi cette
notion de capital risque est ouvert à à
l'épargnant français pour que il place
son argent peut être ailleurs qu'à la
caisse d'epargne simplement pour la
construction et deuxièmement vous l'avez
évoqué donc je voudrais savoir quelle
mesure a été faite mesures quantitatives
sur l'impact sur les investisseurs
étrangers de la mise en place du crédit
impôt compétitivité 20 milliards d'euros
et sur la suppression de la taxe de
solidarité
qu'est ce que ça a apporté merci
monsieur le président le ministre
une observation et de questions
d'observation les amener à me déplacer
très souvent est ce que j'observe c'est
que l'équipe france a du mal à se mettre
en place elle se met en place avec des
acteurs qui sont parfois en concurrence
les uns avec les autres alors qu'ils
sont tous français et devrait
à j en ai travaillé sur un seul objectif
mais dont moi je vois en fait un
avantage dans le rapprochement du
commerce extérieur et du tourisme avec
le ministère des affaires étrangères
parce que au moins il y à un ambassadeur
qui est le représentant du président de
la république à l'étranger et qui
pourraient et qui peut enfin qui
commence à le faire en tout cas essayer
d'organiser toute cette équipe france
pour qu'elle puisse gagner deux
questions la première est ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas avoir une feuille de route
qui serait donnée à la fois aux
ambassadeurs qui ont des lettres de
mission mais qui serait partagé avec les
parlementaires qui dans le cadre de la
diplomatie parlementaire se déplace
aussi beaucoup le cadre des groupes
d'amitié ou des missions spécifiques une
feuille de route qui décrirait ce que
veut et fait la france pour que l'on
puisse accompagner les projets et
surtout vendre la france à l'étranger et
deuxième question est ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas imaginer vous avez dit que
les investisseurs étrangers avaient posé
cette question sur ce que nous faisons
imaginez une communication au niveau de
l'état français dans les médias
étrangers qui sont plus à même à
présenter les grèves d'air france et
d'autres mouvements sociaux en france
que de décrire les succès de la france
une communication pour faire connaître
justement les chiffres et ça irait dans
le sens un petit peu de ce que vient de
suggérer gilbert roger c'est à dire de
redonner confiance aux français mais
également de présenter cette france qui
est aimée à l'étranger qui fait rêver
encore d'un grand pays comme la turquie
qui a demandé à nouveau pouvoir entrer
dans l'union européenne tout simplement
parce que l'union européenne et la
france en particulier attirer continuer
à tirer je crois qu'on ne joue pas
suffisamment de cette image que l'on a à
l'étranger qui est soutenu par des
réseaux exceptionnelle de
culturels éducatifs diplomatiques ne
sont peut-être le seul pays au monde à
avoir de tels réseaux et on ne sait pas
les utiliser comme peuvent le faire les
les anglo saxons en particulier qui se
repose sur les anciens étudiants sur les
alumines de différentes natures et nous
nous avons tout cela en place et on
semble pas capable d'articuler des
objectifs clairs unique qu'ils soient
partagés par tous les liens du rouge 3
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
chen ministre j'ai eu il ya quelques
semaines le plaisir de vous rencontrer
pour vous parler d'un sujet j'aime bien
la phrase au de ceux qui nous quittent
important pour nous qui et
stmicroelectronics je voudrais si vous
pouviez faire le point nous faire le
poids sur à la fois l'évolution de ce
dossier dans notre rapport avec les
italiens et finalement est ce qu'on est
dans cet escompte continue à être dans
cette volonté de faire ce qu'on poussait
un peu c'est à dire l'air d'en faire un
airbus de la microélectronique qu'est ce
qu'on essaye de de poursuivre cette idée
deuxième chose on a vu avec matthias
fekl l'autre jour que 65 % du commerce
de notre pays se faisait avec les pays
européens
donc ma question était et de dire
aujourd'hui comment on travaille de
manière stratégique sur les grands
projets y compris de connectivité est ce
qu'on peut arriver à travailler sur ces
idées pour faire en sorte que les
échanges entre nos pays au sein de
l'europe viennent aussi conforter ses
investissements et cette vision j'allais
dire mondial de thé
avec une compétence dont les
départements souvent c'est est saisi et
à juste titre parce que c'est un peu
leur histoire il y à aussi bien sûr une
compétition de ces grandes régions le
rôle évidemment de